네. 안녕하세요.
빌사남미노크 김수입니다. 어, 최근에
저희 반포동 투자 관련해 가지고
댓글이 좀 많이 달리더라고요. 그래서
제가 오늘 반포동에 대해서 좀 얘기를
해 보려고 합니다. 어, 저희
BSN의 이지혜중계사님을 모셔서 좀
자세하게 이야기 나눠 보도록
하겠습니다.
네. 그래서 요즘에 그 반포동 얘기가
좀 많잖아요. 그래서 아파트들도 되게
최고과 경신하고 있고 반포동에
아파트도 있을 거고 뭐 빌딩도 있을
것 같은데 중개사님 생각은 좀
어떠세요? 어떤 걸 투자하는게 좋을
것 같아? 반포동은 아파트 쪽으로는
상급지라고 생각을 하거든요. 근데
빌딩 쪽으로는 좀 상급지가 아니지
않나라고 생각을 합니다. 처음 투자를
하시는 분들한테는 반포동 아파트를
건내 드리고 싶고요. 좀
다주택자분들한테는
빌딩을 건내 드리고 싶습니다. 그
반포동에 아파트가 많잖아요. 그래서
제일 좋다라고 생각하는 아파트. 네.
지금은 원베일리가 아닐까요?
원베일리가 왜 좋아 보이세요?
원밸리는 일단 한강 조망권이 되어
있으면서 또 거기 앞에 재건축 부지가
완성이 되면 반포에 한강의 퍼즐이
맞춰진다라고 얘기를 많이
하시더라고요. 그렇게 되면 원베일리와
이제 그 옆에 있는 재건축 부지 DH
클래스트가 완성이 되면서 좀 더
경쟁력이 있게 가격이 상승하지 않을까
생각이 듭니다.음
저 약간 그 한남 더일파예요. 아
거기는 누구나 다 약간 뒤에 산책로
있고 조용하고 약간 그런 거 좋아해서
제 개인적인 생각입니다. 근데 물론
이제 지금 한국 정서상 한강 뷰에
따라서 지금 가격이 진짜 왔다 갔다
하는 거 같거든요. 그래서 뭐 투자
관점에서는 한강부가 좋지만 어뭐 개인
차 때문에 뭐 이렇게 수비는 곳에 더
선호하신다는 거죠. 그죠. 그죠.
그래서아서 좋아하는 사람들이 많아요.
그 서울숲 뷰가 좋아서네. 거기에
살고 있는 분들은 사실 많이 안 가게
되더라고요. 저도 서울숲 안 가요.
네. 서울숲 자주 안 가게
되더라고요. 너무 관광객들이 많아서
예전에는 외국인 분들이 와서
운동하면서 저희도 조용하게 운동을
했었는데 이제는 관광객들 때문에
피곤함을 좀 느껴서 저는 잘 안 가고
있습니다. 저는 올림픽 공원을 가요.
차리 차로 이동을 해서 네. 올림픽
공원이나 석촌 후천수는 요번에 갔는데
너무 사랑이 많았고 올림픽 공원을
가서 차라리 음. 산책을 하고 있는
상황입니다. 아파트 얘기는 여기까지
하고 빌딩 얘기를 좀 해 볼 건데 그
저는 개인적으로 그 학원가 있는
반포동은 그나마 임대가 좀 되는데 네
노년역이라든지 뭐 저기 신노년역 그
옆쪽에 있는 반포동은 인대상이 좋지
않은 거 같거든요. 어떻게 보세요?
저번 주에 새벽 답사를 반포동을
우연치 않게 돌게 됐는데 하락거래된
매물들을 많이 보게 되었고 그렇게
되면서 반포동이 지금 투자를 하는게
맞나라고도 생각을 좀 했습니다. 경부
고속도로 이제 지하 되면 거기 뭐 더
좋아질 거 아니냐 뭐 이런 얘기도
하는데 어떻게 생각? 어, 일단은
반포동 아파트나 단순하게 빌딩 평단가
시세만 조사를 해도 아파트가 평단가가
더 높게 지금 나와 있어요. 그리고
반포동 빌딩은 8,에서 1억 3천
정도로 거래된 걸로 확인해 보면
반포동은 주거 시설의 입지가 더 좋고
근생 시설론 좀 학원가나 이런 부분을
제외하고는 투자하기에는 좀
적합 소신은 개인 생각이니까. 네.
투자하기 할 때는 좀 타이밍을 잘
맞춰서 들어가야 되지 않나 싶습니다.
음. 저도 개인적인 생각을 좀 하자면
지하 되고 거기 이제 좀 이렇게 뭐
공원처럼 만든다라고 하는데 저는 이게
상권의 양극화도 되게 심하거든요.
사람들이 이렇게 다 분산되는게 아니라
요즘에 이게 쏠림 형상이 심한 거
같아요. 지금 살고 계시는 성수동이
엄청 쏠려 있고. 예. 그리고 이제
거기에 사실 이게 뭔가 걸어다닐게
있어야 되거든요. 이게 뭐
걸어다니면서 뭐 상가도 들어가고 막
해야 되는데 사실 아직까지 거기가
그렇게 막 개발이 좀 덜 돼 있어서
그리고 이쪽으로는 너무 아파트만 있고
담장이 이렇게 있잖아요. 네. 그래서
뭔가 걸어다니기도 좀 애매한 거
같아요. 제 개인적인 생각은. 근데
저는 그게
될까요라는 이제 의문이 좀 생겨서
네. 되면 너무 좋을 것 같지만 지금
현재론 저희도 이제 브리핑을 나갈 때
네. 어, 그거에 대해서 확신을
드리지는 못하고 있습니다. 네. 일단
오늘 영상을 좀 정리해 보면 그
아파트랑 빌딩이랑은 조금 다르게
보셔야 될 거 같고 뭐 공통적인
얘기는 이제 아파트는 되게 좋다.
반포도. 네. 그리고 특히
원베일리는 제일 좋은 거 같고 그래서
투자 가치로는 아파트는 반포동에 하는
거를 되게 추천하고 그럼 대장
아파트들. 그리고 반대로 이제 빌딩은
상대적으로이 아파트보다는 투자 가치는
조금 떨어지는 거 같고. 네. 그
학원가 있는 반포동은 그나마 이제
조금 괜찮은데 저기 지금
노년역이라든지 뭐 신노년역이라든지
거기 이면에 있는 빌딩들은 지금 뭐
상황이 좋지 않은 거 같다. 그래서
뭐 지금 투자하려고 하면은 되게
신중하게 투자를 해야 될 거 같다.
네. 어, 일단은 뭐 이제
중계사님이랑 좀 얘기해 봤는데 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다.
감사합니다. 감사합니다.